okay the arrests continue to be made in
relation to the january six trump riots
even though it's been uh 14 months and
three days
since the day of the riots we still see
arrests being made and some of these are
major and the latest one is that proud
boys leader enrique tario has been
arrested
in his underruse he was pulled out of
bed yes uh boxers or briefs not exactly
the main question that
law enforcement was asking when they
pulled him out of bed and arrested him
this is a this is a major major deal
daily beast reporting proud boys leader
dragged out of bed in his underwear to
face conspiracy charge
and uh apparently taken by complete
surprise former proud boys ringleader
enrique tario was handcuffed in nothing
but his skivvies early tuesday morning
as police arrived at his miami home to
arrest him for conspiracy
relating to the january sixth
insurrection in footage of the arrest 38
year old tario can be seen exiting with
his house ra his hands raised
surrendering to police he wasn't at the
riot having been unavoidably detained
that is arrested two days before for
burning a stolen black lives matter flag
but the feds allege he organized
alongside five other proud boys members
the attack on the capital the riot was
the final stage of a convoluted plot
involving a flurry of text messages
social media posts and a meeting in a dc
parking garage on january 5th
tario was released from prison for the
flag burning incident two months ago he
has now been arrested once again the the
video is pretty wild
we have there's video of him uh being
pulled out of the house in his uh in his
in his ruse as i mentioned um
and uh the next thing would be well it
would be great if the politicians who
supported the january sixth insurrection
were treated in the exact same way it
would it would really be something by
the way
uh to say
to see josh hawley arrested in a diaper
i'm sorry in in his underwear um it
would really be something else and it
would even be more interesting to see
attorney general merrick garland in his
pajamas
arresting trump wearing uh wearing
briefs or whatever in all seriousness
this enrique tario guy is really really
not a good guy now some of you may know
about the proud boys and some may not
the the proud boys is a
far
far far right
what's called neo-fascist group by many
it's
as far as i know it's an exclusively
male organization although it's
conceivable that i mean i don't know how
official membership is anyway it's
conceivable there may be there may be
some uh women involved
to some degree
tario specifically
is um a cuban-american and afro-cuban
ethnically
and uh some say well that's kind of uh
kind of interesting that this right-wing
neo-fascist group
allows him in or whatever uh but uh yes
they as long as you are willing to have
the right views there apparent
apparently are no race-based tests for
neo-fascist proud boy membership but
this guy could really be facing
very very serious penalties and for if
the name sounds familiar
for a year
there has been discussion of is tario
going to be arrested
for his role in inciting planning
whatever the january six riots and uh
the answer is that indeed he has been
and of course uh when it takes this
usually from what i've been reading and
some of the lawyers i spoke to when
things take this long it's because they
really would it's not because they wait
until later investigators
for the more serious charges it's that
the more serious charges often are more
complicated to prove and to feel good
that you're ready to charge and so it
just takes longer to build the case
that's what lawyers have told me
um and and we will ultimately see what
happens with tario but we expected that
this was potentially coming uh and it
now has
one of our sponsors is
coffee cometeer coffee is delicious i
can tell you firsthand and they've
discovered the best way to brew preserve
and deliver coffee their brewing process
captures over 2 000 flavor compounds
then the coffee is flash frozen locking
in the flavor it arrives at your home
frozen in a fully recyclable capsule all
you have to do is melt it by adding hot
water or cold water for iced coffee it
takes seconds it's the most convenient
way that i have ever made coffee i've
been impressed with how the process
protects the flavor i really enjoy
commentary they have a variety of flavor
options light medium and dark single
origin and blended coffee roasts from
the best specialty roasters you'll get
twenty dollars off when you go to
cometer.com
pacman the link is underneath this video